تطورات عسكريه ميدانيه متسرعه في جنوب
اوكرانيا بين الانسحاب الروسي وطبعا اعاده
السيطره الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه انسحبت
و بشكل مفاجئ من مدينه خرسون تمركزت على
الجهه المقابله لنهر دنيبرو طبعا هذا
الانسحاب سمح للقوات الاوكرانيه من
استعاده السيطره على المدينه في عمليه
تثبت بالحذر خوفا من كمين روسي قد يكون
وراء عمليه الانسحاب بعد الانسحاب الروسي
تحول نهر دنبرو الى حدود تفصل بين القوات
الروسيه في شرق النهر والاكرانيه في غربه
القوات الاوكرانيه وما انت مركز في خرسان
بدات بوضع خطه لاستعاده شمال الشرقي
وبالتالي بدات اوكرانيا بحجم قوات لمعركه
زمولوجيا وفتح طريق رئيسي يسمح لها
بالتحرك ايضا في ميليتو بول ذات الاهميه
الاقليميه طبعا هذا هو الوضع قرصان
وزباريجيا ولكن كيف وصلنا الى هنا
انسحابات روسيه عديده وراء ذلك الا ان
الانسحاب من خرسون يعتبر الاكبر منذ بدايه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا الانسحاب لم يكن الاول هو
طبعا عده خساره لموسكو كما يقول الغرب
وتكتيك عسكري بحسب موسكو الانسحاب للقوات
الروسيه كان في مارس الماضي هنا من شمال
شرقي كيف بعد اخر جوله من المفاوضات التي
كانت باسطنبول والتي اظهرت من خلالها
روسيا مبادره حسينيه القوات الروسيه
تجاهلت من بعدها لاقليم الدوم باس ولبعض
المناطق المطله على بحر ازوف غير انها
انسحبت من جزء منها منتصف شهر سبتمبر على
الماضي القوات الروسيه انسحبت ايضا من
خايف ولمان في خطوه لتعزيز وضعها في مناطق
اخرى وتحديدا في لوغاز